esta es una imagen de isaac newton quien
fue un mate más matemático y físico
británico y de este otro lado tenemos a
gottfried leibniz quien también fue
filósofo y matemático y que fue
contemporáneo ya isaac newton quizás no
tan famoso como él pero bueno estos dos
caballeros juntos fueron los padres
fundadores del cálculo e hicieron la
mayor parte de su trabajo digamos a
finales de los 1600 y este señor de aquí
es usain bolt que hasta ahora en 2013
parece ser él el ser humano más rápido
que hay sobre la tierra y quizás
probablemente es el más rápido que ha
existido en la historia de la humanidad
y quizás aún no hayas hecho la
asociación con estos tres personajes
quizás podrías pensar que no tienen
mucho en común pero ellos se han hecho
la misma pregunta fundamental y que es
la misma que el cálculo diferencial
atiende y es la pregunta de cuál es la
tasa instantánea de cambio de algo en el
caso de usain bolt ok es que tan rápido
se está moviendo justo ahora no su
velocidad promedio
en el último segundo o su velocidad
promedio en los próximos diez segundos
sino que tan rápido se está yendo justo
ahora y eso es lo que el cálculo
diferencial se trata así que vamos a
escribirlo el cálculo el cálculo
diferencial
diferencial justamente aborda el
problema de las tasas instantáneas de
cambio que la tasa instantánea
la tasa instantánea
y realmente todo se trata de qué es lo
que está pasando en este instante en
este mismo instante y para pensarlo
realmente pues pues realmente ver que no
es un problema tan sencillo para abordar
con el álgebra tradicional así que
déjenme dibujar una gráfica por aquí que
íbamos a pintar unos ejes digamos aquí
tenemos nuestros ejes digamos que aquí
en el eje ya tenemos la distancia ok
vamos a calcular la distancia en función
de x que va a ser el tiempo el tiempo
muy bien entonces lo que yo voy a hacer
es graficar un poco de lo que hace
usain bolt usain bolt en su en sus
carreras digamos sabemos que usain bolt
bueno al inicio cuando el tiempo todavía
no avanza es decir cuando el tiempo es
cero pues no se ha movido verdad todavía
se está preparando para salir corriendo
sin embargo sabemos que este señor a los
9.58 segundos puede recorrer
metros 100 metros los puede recorrer en
100 9.58 segundos entonces lo que
podemos nosotros hacer es calcular la
velocidad promedio la velocidad promedio
voy a ponerlo completito velocidad
promedio y esto no es otra cosa más que
el cambio el cambio que hace en la
distancia la distancia recorrida muy
bien entre el cambio en el tiempo o el
tiempo que le tomó llegar hasta ese
final muy bien y eso pues no es otra
cosa más que nuestro cambio en nuestra
variable ya que es la distancia sobre
nuestro cambio en la variable x que es
el tiempo y si recuerdas muy bien de tus
clases de álgebra o quizás de otros
vídeos puedes ver que esto no es otra
cosa más que la pendiente de la recta
que conecta estos dos puntos verdad de
este lado nosotros tenemos el cambio en
el cambio en que son 100 metros 100
metros mientras que aquí tenemos nuestro
cambio en x qué
justamente 9.58 segundos entonces esto
de aquí es fácilmente calculable y estos
serán 100 metros entre en 9.58 segundos
esta es una forma de calcular la la
velocidad
instante bueno no más bien la velocidad
promedio ya que recorrió esos 100 metros
y para ver esto más claro vamos a sacar
la calculadora y ver justamente bueno
aquí ya tenía una práctica pero tenemos
100 metros entre 9.58 y eso que nos da
eso nos da 10.43 que lo voy a dejar
simplemente como 10.4 más o menos 10.4 y
las unidades son metros sobre segundo
que son justamente las unidades de la
velocidad
así que si uno quisiera por ejemplo
calcular la cantidad de metros que ha
recorrido en una hora pues simplemente
hay que multiplicarlo por 3600 que son
la cantidad de vamos a hacer los 10
puntos 10.4 por 3600 3.600 que es la
cantidad de segundos que hay en una hora
y eso nos da 37 mil 440 metros que son
37 kilómetros aproximadamente 37
kilómetros y medio y bueno eso
comparándolo con un carro es bastante
bueno si el carro va va lento pues no sé
yo hago la comparación y me parece
bastante rápido ahora si tu carro a lo
mejor está dado en millas
digamos donde marca la velocidad está
dado en millas por hora bueno
simplemente hay que hay que hay que
dividir entre 1600 porque una milla es
aproximadamente 1600 entonces si
dividimos entre 1600 esto será igual a
23 puntos
millas por hora entonces vamos a dejarlo
así esto es aproximadamente 2023 23.46
millas bueno vamos a hacer los 23.5 de
una vez 23.5 millas por hora aunque hay
por ahora ahora vamos a pensar no sólo
en en esta velocidad promedio sino
déjenme hacer la gráfica aproximada de
cómo es que usain bolt hace su recorrido
digamos que al inicio pues empieza con
una velocidad pequeña
no va no arranca luego luego como como
si fuera la mitad de la carrera sino que
va un poco lento hasta que alcanza su
máxima velocidad y después quizás por el
cansancio empieza a desacelerar hasta
que llega a la meta que son 100 metros
entonces como puedes ver aquí en estos
100 metros no tiene la misma velocidad
que realmente calculamos en la velocidad
promedio sino que ya lleva una velocidad
mucho menor ahora bien como puedes notar
la velocidad realmente la podemos pensar
como la pendiente de digamos de aquí de
una línea tangente a la curva entonces
esa velocidad como puedes ver la
pendiente no es la misma en todos los
puntos aquí por ejemplo va un poco baja
y después alcanza su máximo pico de
velocidad es la digamos la pendiente más
pronunciada y después al ir
desacelerando se va relajando esa
velocidad entonces lo que estuve
buscando es que la velocidad máxima que
se le ha detectado a usain bolt es de 30
millas por hora 30 millas por hora
entonces puedes pensar
aquí tenemos una pendiente de 30 millas
por hora ok no importa realmente cuáles
no que el detalle es que es un cambio
instantáneo y lo más rápido que se le ha
detectado es de 30 millas por hora pero
puedes ver que calcularlo no es algo muy
trivial de hacer podrías decir ok déjame
intentar aproximar la pendiente en este
punto justo de la siguiente forma vamos
a hacer un cambio en x vamos a hacer un
cambio en x y que eso nos provoque un
cambio en g
ok entonces aquí podemos calcular la el
cambio promedio con esta con esta con
este cambio en x y con este cambio en ye
y nuestra idea entonces es hacer lo
siguiente y lo que vamos a hacer es
bueno ya que tengo esta aproximación qué
pasaría si yo hiciera este cambio en el
tiempo cada vez más y más y más y más
pequeño porque por supuesto esta curva
no es constante
no es recta verdad el cambio no es
constante entonces si queremos hacer
esto
o bueno queremos calcular el cambio
instantáneo lo que tenemos que hacer es
hacer que el cambio en x la delta x sea
cada vez más pequeño o en otras palabras
más técnicas queremos hacer el límite
cuando nuestro cambio en x tiende a cero
del cambio en g sobre el cambio en x muy
bien entonces de esta forma puedes verlo
como el cambio instantáneo la pendiente
instantánea en este punto de la curva ok
y eso lo puedes hacer en cualquier punto
o si lo expresamos ya en términos de lo
que trabajamos en cálculo esto no es
otra cosa más que la derivada de de la
función y con respecto a x que en este
caso es el tiempo ya eso justamente es a
lo que se le llama la derivada esto es
la derivada y reserve esta anotación de
de xy de ella porque estamos estamos
relacionando esto con la palabra
diferencial
esto es digamos déjenme
esto es una diferencial de iu y esto es
una diferencial de nx y otra forma de
conceptualizar esto que es la
diferencial es un cambio infinitesimal
mente pequeño en g y este es un cambio
infinitesimal mente pequeño en x y al
hacer estos cambios muy muy pero muy muy
chiquitos en tanto en ye como en x
podremos ser capaces de obtener está
pendiente instantánea o en para este
caso de este ejemplo que es la velocidad
instantánea de usain bolt justo en ese
momento y puedes notar que no no podemos
poner cero entre cero verdad si ponemos
aquí que el cambio en x es cero es decir
ya no sólo aproximamos sino que hacemos
el cambio en x igual a cero pues esto
nos queda algo indeterminado verdad no
podemos dividir por ceros así que
necesitamos tomar el límite cuando se
aproxima a cero y eso lo definiremos de
forma más rigurosa en los próximos
vídeos